-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
It's time to play Jinx!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, our first team tonight,
he's the host
of "Love Connection," on Fox,
and he's the host
of "The Tonight Show," on NBC.
It's Andy Cohen
and Jimmy Fallon!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-And their opponents.
He is the legendary emcee
of the legendary Roots crew,
and she stars
in the new movie, "Ocean's 8."
It's Tariq Trotter
and Mindy Kaling!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Now, the rules
of this game are simple.
I will read
your team a category.
-You're yelling right now.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and what do we do?
You read the category?
-Then, I will read
your team a category.
-Yep.
-Then, you will count to three.
-And you will both say
the same thing at the same time.
-That's a jinx!
-Yes!
-That's a jinx, okay good.
Because we want to get a jinx.
-Partners,
put on your Jinx gloves.
-Okay, let's put on
our Jinx gloves.
-Oh, my God!
-These are the Jinx gloves.
All right.
-These are gonna meld your minds
into one.
-Why do we put
these gloves on again?
-So you meld your minds
into one.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh.
-This is good.
-I feel good about this.
-Oh, nice.
All right.
Jinx gloves in place.
-This is so weird.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's weird.
-I have all
of Tariq's memories now.
-Oh, wow.
It's really working already.
Wow.
-Oh, my God.
-It's like a movie. Okay.
-Mindy and Tariq.
-Yeah.
-You are up.
May I have the category, please?
-Oh, gosh.
-Oh, wow!
-That's some high technology.
-What?!
-Yeah, you got the tube, man.
-What's the budge for this show?
-We got the tube, man.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay, this is not fair
for you guys.
"The other names for marijuana."
-No, come on!
-Okay, come on.
Tariq --
-Okay, okay.
-This is rigged.
-Other names for marijuana?
Other names for marijuana.
Whenever you guys are ready.
-Andy would crush at that.
-Three, two, one.
-Okay.
All right.
-Three, two, one.
-Reefer.
-Weed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Reefer.
-Reefer!
-Mindy, are you from 1954?
-I'm from 1954.
-Your partner is Chong.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
"Reefer" is the best.
That was fantastic.
-What's wrong with me?
-I like "reefer."
-What's wrong --
I'm from "L.A. Confidential."
[ Laughter ]
-"Reefer" is great.
-All right, try it again.
This is for 2 points.
Try it again.
-Wait, no, okay.
I don't know any more.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
One will come to you.
-You're a writer.
-One will come to you.
-Ready?
-You're filled with synonyms.
-Can Steve tell me one?
-No, he can't do one.
-Connect with me.
-Connect with Tariq.
-Let's do it, let's do it.
-Ready? You got it.
-Yeah.
-One, two, three.
Grass.
-...grass.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
-This is so --
-I'm sorry, they got it.
2 points.
Judges said it.
Judges said it -- 2 points.
-Hey, hey.
The confetti has spoken.
-Oh, my God.
-Let's see the next category.
-Reefer.
-Okay.
-So embarrassing.
-Ready?
-Wow. This game show
has a big budge.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Again, this is cheating
for Jimmy.
Category's "Nuts."
[ Laughter ]
Nuts.
-Okay.
-Types of nuts --
-We got this.
-Okay.
-Nuts.
-Yeah. Like popular --
-Popular nuts.
-Nuts. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Three, two, one.
-Almonds.
-Peanuts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-The hell --
-Who the hell eats almonds?
-That is the most obvious nut.
-Oh, give me a break!
You love Snoopy!
-No, yours!
-What is Snoopy from?!
-I got it wrong!
-What is Snoopy from?
You love snoopy.
-I agree! I got it wrong!
-What is it, the comic strip?
-"Peanuts"!
-That's right!
Not almonds!
[ Laughter ]
-All right, ready?
-I'm a low-fat --
-Oh, are you doing like a --
-Are you doing low-fat thing?
-You look good.
-All right, ready, bud?
-All right, ready?
-We need another nut?
-Another nut, very easy.
-2 points.
-Ready? One, two, three.
Walnut!
-Cashew.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Kit Kat?!
He said Kit Kat!
-Cashew!
Cashew!
-What the hell is happening?!
-Cashew!
-My arm hurts me.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Don't say Almond Joy.
-Walnut -- there's the word
"nut" in the name walnut!
[ Laughter ]
Cashew?!
It doesn't even have the word
nut in it!
-Almond doesn't
even have the word nut.
Peanut, walnut -- names of nuts!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-All right.
-I'm very disappointed
in myself.
-That's okay.
-You can get it.
-I don't even know other nuts.
-1 point.
There's another nut coming up.
Ready? You guys ready?
-Oh, we're doing another nut!
-One more time.
You get three times.
-I gotta think of another nut?
-Yeah.
-Oh, God, hold on, hold on.
-I got one!
I got one, I got one.
-You do?
-Yes.
-Hold on.
Did you say --
Oh, I can't.
-Ready?
-Yeah, that's the nut.
That's the nut he's thinking of.
-Three, two, one.
-Hazelnut!
-Almond!
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
I can't believe I said almond.
-You said almond already!
You can't say it twice!
It didn't work the first time!
[ Laughter ]
-I was --
[ Laughing ]
-So I said it had
the word "nut" in it!
-No.
-As in nut-tella, Nutella!
Nut, nut, nut, nut, nut,
nut, nut, nut, nut, nut!
-Who said almond already?
-You said almond, yeah.
-Keep the game moving!
My hands are getting sweaty.
-All right, back --
It's back --
-At least I'm consistent.
-Yeah, you are a consistent.
That was good.
-I can't believe
I already said it.
-Don't go nuts.
All right.
Mindy and Tariq, back to you.
Can I have a category please?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
Oh.
I'm shvitzing.
[ Laughter ]
-God, you got burned again.
These are words
that rhyme with "junk."
-Junk?
-Words that rhyme with "junk."
-How dare you.
-What?
Words that rhyme with "junk."
-I don't know.
Let's not overthink it.
-At least there's no nuts in it.
Oh, wait. There is.
-We're good, we're good.
-You ready?
-Yes.
-Three, two, one.
Punk.
-Trunk.
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
-Punk?
-What'd you say?
-I said trunk.
-I said punk.
-You said punk?
-Trunk and punk.
-This is harder than it seems.
-It is harder than it appears.
-What other words are there?
-Well, there's --
-Okay.
-Just try -- one will come out.
-Oh, I'm so sorry.
There's a million nuts...
[ Laughter ]
...that you guys
can choose from.
-There's a million words
that rhyme with --
-Okay, Tariq.
-I'm sorry.
-They get very competitive.
They get very competitive.
-My arm is killing me.
-We said punk, and we said...
-And we said trunk.
-Trunk, and you said punk.
-And it has to rhyme with junk?
-Yes.
-Yeah. Ready?
Here we go.
-Three, two, one.
-Monk!
-Dunk.
Monk?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-What were you gonna say?
-Okay.
-Hey, Tariq.
Hey, Tariq.
-Okay.
So is this the last one?
-Yeah, you get one more chance.
-Now there's no more words.
-No, there's one more.
-There's more.
-Come on.
-Let's look into
each other's eyes.
-Don't do that thing
you did last time.
-Three, two, one.
-Lunk.
-Funk.
[ Rim shot ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Hold it.
Can we -- Can we --
-What did you say -- lunk?
-Lunk.
-Lunk?
-Like a lunkhead.
The old-fashioned word lunkhead.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I love you.
All right, Jimmy and Andy.
You're up next.
May I have the category, please?
-I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
-Lunk.
-Oh, my God, my arm.
-Oh, so we had nuts, junk,
and one more -- body parts.
This is body parts.
That is the category.
Body parts.
-Body parts.
-We can get this.
-Parts of the body.
The human body.
-Oh, okay, okay.
-Ready?
-Okay, okay.
-Three, two, one.
Arms!
Yeah!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
They have swept into the lead!
This is a real
barn burner, folks -- 3-2.
-I'm, like, punch drunk.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, hey, what's up?
You got...
-What do I got --
Thank you.
-What happens now?
-Now they get one more shot.
-Okay.
-How many points do we have?
-You guys have 3.
-Oh.
-You have 2.
-I'm very stressed out.
-All right, ready?
Are you guys ready?
-Relax. Just take a deep breath.
It's all good.
-Thank you Steve, okay.
-Let's see the category.
-Mindy, you can do this.
-You've been getting
easier categories than us.
-♪ I believe in you ♪
-Thank you.
-Ready?
Okay, this is rappers.
Rappers.
-Okay, we can do this.
-This is rappers.
You guys can do this.
-Who -- Okay.
Before -- Who would I pick?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Okay. Can I say any more?
No.
-Yeah, you go three --
-Three.
-Okay.
-Three, two, one.
-Jay Z.
-Drake.
-[ Gasps ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
-That's all right.
That's all right.
That's okay, that's okay.
Come on, you got another one.
You can get this.
-They get another chance?
-Who would I pick?
-Oh! She just gave out
the hand signal!
-I said, "Who would I pick?"
-That's a hand signal.
-Who would I pick?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
You ready?
-Yeah.
-Three --
-One, two --
-Three, two, one.
-Childish Gambino.
-Nikki Minaj.
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
-Okay, you can still
tie this up.
-What?
They get another try?
-You got three.
You got three nuts.
You guys named six nuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Our arms are killing us.
-You give me a hint through...
-Okay.
-Rappers. Famous rappers.
-Rappers, here we go.
-Ready?
-Three, two, one.
-Black Th--
-Eazy-E.
-Oh!
[ Buzzer ]
-Did you say P?
-Did you say Jay Z again?
-No, I said Eazy-E.
-Eazy-E. There you go.
-Whoa.
[ Air horn blares ]
Oh! You know what that means!
-What?
-Time for the final round.
-Oh!
-First team
to get Jinx gets 10 points.
-Oh, my God.
-10 points.
-10 points?
Okay.
Jimmy and Andy, you're up first.
You will get one chance to Jinx.
Otherwise,
Mindy and Tariq can steal.
May I see the category, please?
-Oh, my God.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-The category is...
-Mm-hmm.
...holidays.
-Okay.
-Holidays.
-You ready?
Are you ready?
Come on.
-You ready?
-Whenever you guys are ready.
Holidays.
Ready?
-Three, two, one.
-Hanukkah!
-Christmas!
Jimmy!
[ Buzzer ]
-You're Jewish!
-Okay.
Okay! Okay!
Hanukkah?!
What's wrong with you?!
-I love Christmas!
It's my favorite!
-No! You're Andy Cohen!
You're Jewish!
-I know!
-Hanukkah!
You celebrate Hanukkah!
You don't celebrate Christmas!
-You people drive it
down our faces!
-Oh, please.
[ Laughter ]
-Mindy and Tariq.
-Okay.
-You can steal.
-The category is --
-...logos is like a menorah!
-Holidays.
-Logo.
-Don't you have a thing?
It says --
-Oh, now you're typecasting.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
Are we ready? Are we ready?
-All right, ready?
-Okay.
-Okay. Mindy?
-Yes, we can do this.
-Holidays.
Don't say Christmas or Hanukkah.
-Three, two, one.
Halloween!
-Oh!
[ Ding! ]
-There you have it!
The winners!
-Thanks! Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-My thanks to the champs
right there!
Mindy Kaling, Tariq trotter.
My thanks to my partner,
Andy Cohen.